my name is anthony eden
i'm one of the founders of d and simple
the other is darren eden my brother
who's down here today as well
and today i want to talk to you a bit
about using erlang for authoritative dns
so a little bit of background first what
is authoritative dns essentially
whenever you have a domain
on the internet somebody has to
ultimately have authority
to tell the rest of the world where that
domain resolves to
all right and so authoritative dns is
all about being the authoritative
provider
of that dns data another piece is
resolvers
so those are the the recursers that go
out and actually try to determine
who the authority is and then return
data from the authority
so a bit of background at dansimple
we've been running powerdns which is an
open source c plus plus dns server a
fantastic dns server
for three years now and we still have it
running in production on
our unicast network um it's a fantastic
server that can hook up to a back-end
database in our case
uh mysql and and then we also run
postgres as well for our production
database we sync the two up for this
particular case but
it's really fantastic that you can put
in these back ends to it that are custom
and for some of the things that we do
like our alias record
we needed that functionality and we
actually did the first implementations
in ruby
which is kind of insane uh but it works
because it it works off the idea of of a
simple posix pipe where it can
have a co-process that runs in memory
and it can just pass data and
pass the questions in and get responses
back
um there came a point though where it
started to be a performance issue
essentially the the ruby processes were
using lots of resources
that it was consuming lots of time uh to
start giving back responses
and we were essentially being limited
with
what we could do with the throughput
that we could do
so the first thing i started playing
around with when
we realized that we wanted to sort of
see if we could advance our
dns resolution was keeping
power dns but swapping out the back end
implementation
so in one case we might we tried the
idea of having a closure app
that would be running separately and
that there would be in a process
communication that that didn't work too
well
we also tried out the lua back end for
powerdns so lewis seems like a really
great solution because as
in sort of an in-process language it's
really fast it's good as a control
language
so we thought okay this will be the
optimum solution it turned out that
some of the things that we need to do
such as dns resolution from inside of
our authoritative name servers
ended up being difficult it was so
difficult in fact that it was just
became a nightmare
so this was around this was sometime
around summer last year
middle of summer was like july i think
and
i started thinking about well i had
failed a couple times at learning erlang
so i wonder if i could do this again i
had programmed a little bit of closure
i'd started to get the notion of
functional program in my head so i
wonder if
erlang would be an interesting language
to build an authoritative dns server in
now if any of you have ever tried to
build an authoritative dns server
they're actually looks
they're like deceptively simple all
right that's the beauty of them
anybody can write authoritative dns
server and once you try
you realize that no one should ever be
writing an authoritative dns server
it's a mistake it's not the simple
respond to a question that's the hard
part it's all the edge cases
that come from a protocol that's been
around for 25
30 years right but
i have a lot of time on my hands i have
you know four kids so like i've got all
this extra time right so i'm like okay
i'll use this as a platform to learning
a language um
i said well why erlang okay obviously
it's parallel processing it's
known for the ability to have lots of
processes that that can run
independently it's known as a
a functional language without data
sharing so like in basically immutable
data
i thought okay this seems like a really
interesting thing to do
so i started playing around with it the
first iteration
was just sort of learning a little bit
how erlang worked and how how we could
do this how we could use it for an
authoritative data server
and in the process i started
understanding the benefits of erlang
and i realized this this was not only a
good solution in this case it was
exactly the right solution that we
needed to eventually have
and so i i want to just show a few i'm
going to show three of the benefits that
have come up
uh that i've found as i've been working
with erlang in the co
in the context of an authoritative dns
server and i'm going to give you some
code examples as well along the way
so the first one and i think this was a
key one that sort of pushed me over the
site was the the binary bit syntax
inside of erlang
and you'll understand why in a second
basically this is a way of representing
binary data where you can deconstruct a
stream of binary data into internal
structures very easily okay
so let's take a quick look at this bit
of code right here so this is the
function definition
for decoding a dns message
and if you start if you look at
basically how it decodes it very simply
says i can decode
uh these different fields so one is a 16
bit field the next is a one bit field
then a four bit
field and it will basically read all
that in and at the very end you say just
put the rest of it
into another binary stream so keep that
around and we'll use that later
and what's interesting is this maps
almost directly to the original
specifications that are in rfc 1035
that describe a dns packet right i mean
almost exactly this is really cool so um
so i took my ascii art and my binary
syntax and i put the two together and
said wow we have something really
interesting here
if you actually look at this right now
you see that there it has everything
listed out even down to the variable
names are almost
exact with slight difference because the
for example a n count is actually a and
c
which is the answer count authority
count is now auc as opposed to ns count
anyway but the bottom line is they're
basically mapped one to one
so that's the first really interesting
feature dns is is a it's it's a
highly optimized binary protocol of
messages the idea was
what can we fit into this really small
udp packet
and get a response back as fast as
possible all right so it fits well
the second thing that's fantastic in
erlang and as i started to explore more
i started to realize that
when it comes to design of program flow
and it comes to
actually dealing with lots of variety in
the data that's coming in so a data
some sort of piece of data that's
structured similarly but then is treated
differently like subsections of the data
are going to be parsed out differently
depending on the type of data well
pattern matching is a great match for
that
so this is a little bit of code from the
current this and all this i'm pulling is
from an open source project i'll give
you the year at the end called earldns
so all the work almost all the work
that's being done here has all been open
sourced
so you can see all the code later as
well so in this example we see
two functions that are essentially the
same they're eight
this they take the same number of
arguments uh in this case it's a list
with four items in it
and it decides which function to execute
based on in this case one of those
fields
and it's actually it's the second field
in that list so the first one says i
have an a record
so the type comes in as a binary string
in a record and and this is taking
incoming json data that's a
representation of the zone
and it's turning into an in-memory
structure that we can store and access
quickly later on
and so it says well in the case of an a
record it's an ip address
so let me parse that out let me turn
that that binary into an actual or
like parse that address which is a
string it's a binary it's a bit string
and turn that into whatever erlang's
representation is of an ip address in
memory
and then let me construct the the rest
of this the record structure in memory
but if on the other hand it's a cname
record which is the second form then
that function will get invoked
and so essentially when we're dealing
with all these different record types
it's just a series of the same function
with a slightly different signature
that's doing the pattern matching based
on the type and this is a really great
way to sort of say i have a
list of transformations that are not a
list transformation but i have a bunch
of different
data coming in and i want to do
different things based on some parts of
the data
in erlang that's extremely easy so this
was a powerful feature of erlang
that sort of starts showing in the
design of how erlang applications work
the third piece which was extremely
interesting
and this one is i think ultimately the
most important part of erlang
is process as an otp otp is the open
telecom platform but think of it
basically as a
way that describes how to build
applications that can run in parallel
it's how to build
a it takes and it it defines the generic
part of a service and you define the
specific parts of the service
and as an example well first let me talk
about the flow of this so
every every essentially every service in
otp goes through these four steps
essentially spawns the process and when
i talk process in this term i mean
processes in the erlang vm the erlang vm
can have
lots of processes running in parallel
this is not os processes
the erlang vm takes care of spreading
out these processes across the cores in
your machine
so all you're dealing with is inside of
the erlang world and it manages all of
the the process communication inside the
vm
and between those cores and potentially
distributed across many nodes not just
the local node but
across other nodes as well it then
initializes that process
and then it just sits there and
receiving data so receiving messages
essentially until finally it exits out
so that's the standard life cycle
of an otp process as an example i wanted
to show you the packet cache
so inside of an authoritative dns server
you're going to get a lot of the same
questions over and over and over again
and the response isn't going to change
so within say uh you know in our case
our packet cache has a 60 second
time to live uh it's configurable but
i'm going to stick with the 60 second
one but
as within that 60 seconds you may
receive the same query over and over and
over again
it doesn't make sense to go reprocess to
get the answer again we want to cache
the entire question that came in and
just give back a cached answer
so that's how the packet cache works so
here's a little bit of code this is
going to be the most complicated bit of
code and then i'll start talking a
little bit about optimization
some of the things we had to do so this
is an example of a simple otp
process a module just says this is the
namespace that i'm working in all the
modules inside of erlang are flat
and then you have the behavior and this
is a generic server this is basically
just the generic process it can respond
to both synchronous
and asynchronous messages all right then
we export the function calls that we
want to make public so these are the
calls that you actually call on that
module the start link just says
hey start up this process and have it
running
then we have some basic methods for
getting a pack getting basically
something out of the pack of cash
putting something into the pack of cash
sweeping it to clear all of the dead the
packets that have gone beyond their ttl
and clearing out the packet cache
completely to start fresh
the next section is the the generic
server implementation functions
these are not called externally they're
actually called by the otp
process when it's when you send it
messages and then finally there's just
some
some variables there and a record that's
defined that we're going to use to hold
state now the thing that's interesting
about processes
if for those of you who are familiar
with object-oriented languages and
object-oriented languages
an object holds state right and when you
want to active on that state you send
messages to the object typically by
calling a method
well in erlang processes hold state
and you send messages to that process
when you want to modify that state
all right and process state is
completely independent
in almost every case from other process
state there are ways to get around this
sometimes but
in almost every case it's independent
next bit of code so back to the api
that's the api
five functions that describes our packet
cache
this is the implementations the
functions we start up the link
when somebody tries to get something out
of packet as a question
we say okay generic server call the get
packet send a get packet message
with the question when we want to put
the question we put the question and the
response and we say set the packet
this is very straightforward in my in my
opinion now the difference between call
and cast is call is going to be
synchronous so it's going to wait for a
response from the process
whereas the final two sweep and clear
are going to be asynchronous
it's going to cast out that message and
not wait for a response
why because we don't really care about
the sweeping and the clean the clearing
to finish we just want them to be done
all right so we this mixes both
synchronous and asynchronous calls in a
single process
uh here's the initialization so this has
again we see pattern matching here
there's two possible indentations for
this function one is you send no
arguments in
in which case it'll default to say it 20
i said it was a 60 second but
right now we have it to 20 here um the
the other one says i'm sending in a ttl
and configuring it and this is the part
where it says i'm going to have a timer
the timer is going to do various things
going to sweep in this case and then i'm
going to set my
my default state so i'm going to start
with a state that keeps a reference to
the timer
and also the ttl and that state every
time
one of those casts or calls come through
it's going to actually give me that
state at that moment
as part of the function implementation
we'll see that here in just a second so
here's the handle call for the get
packet
it says uh i'm getting the state you see
the third argument in that function call
is the state so that's the current state
in that process
which is basically just a a hash like a
map of data
uh and then it tries to look up inside
of x is a is
a basically a a in memory data store
it's like it's basically an in-memory
hash maps what it is right but it's
really fast optimized to be quite fast
for certain types of things um small
data sets or
actually pretty large too i don't look
down around here anyway the point is
that it looks in the h it looks in
says it tries to find something if it
finds a question that matches
cool then it will check the expiration
date if the if
we hit the cache but it's expired all
right then we'll send back that message
the cache is expired and the
the caller knows what to do in that case
it says oh i'll just continue on into
the
into resolving that record um
if the cat the packet is good
then we'll go ahead and reset the timer
on it so the packet will stay around a
little bit longer and we'll return back
the response
um actually in this case we don't reset
it but we could have done that and then
the final one is is
there was a cash miss and it sends back
that cash mission again the caller
knows what to do in this case the caller
says okay i just need to go through the
resolution
this is for getting the packet same
thing and basically it
sorry this is for setting the packet and
it inserts the packet into x
with the the current time stamp and the
end
with the ttl added on to it uh
this sweeps the packet cache the first
function and that will actually it does
a little bit of
look up in ets to try to find all of the
packets that are expired
and then it will delete them from the
data structure
and then the final one is clear which
basically says just remove all objects
that are part of this packet cache so
that's that process is running inside
the erlang vm completely independent
from all the other processes
and erlang handles the responsibility
for managing
the that process and if there are any
errors to handling the failure of it and
restarting the process
or the exiting of the process things
like that which is really powerful
because we don't have to manage any of
that
we just have to follow the otp
principles and we have this completely
independent process with its own memory
space really powerful in my opinion
so what are some of the challenges
though if you're going to be
working in erlang that was the initial
thing was great i found these things
that work
um but now we talk about what are the
things that are difficult when you're
working with erlang
example the first one and this is when
you start with the language it's just
thinking in terms of erlang it's
thinking in terms of functions and
processes
and if you come from a language where
you're you have object-oriented syntax
or you have procedural syntax it's going
to be strange
that you always have to pass the state
through a function you there's no
shared state anywhere all right so when
you call a function you need to get it
give it everything that it's going to
work with
and it will give you everything back
that's the resulting transformation of
whatever the end result was of its
calculation
and transforming data versus updating
data is
hard to get used to at first but that's
a beginner's problem that's the problem
that once you pass that and you learn
that processes are essentially the way
that erlang can deal with state
that lives a long period of time and
then functions are designed to just do
the processing without having any shared
state
then it starts to make sense so you get
past the the
the early challenge and go to the later
challenge
so the next question is how do you
operate an airline system
the reason being the reason that becomes
a challenge is because
erlang systems are essentially their
this entire
os for applications that sits on top
of your existing operating system and it
has an entire tool set
that it's designed to work with it
explicitly
and it doesn't necessarily work with the
standard tools like top that you might
be used to
in say a unix environment and so for
example
when they switched from r14 to r15 which
is the release version of erlang
there's a lot of confusion because the
cpus were always running
and they were like what's going on here
this thing's using up on my cpu well no
the vm was was staying hot
because it actually turns out it takes
more time to spin up something to
process rather than just to keep it warm
for a little longer waiting
for the next message but it got a lot it
created a lot of confusion some great
articles out there about this
but this it requires a completely
different mindset to operate
an erlang system so that was a
significant challenge
and finally you have to learn to work
around what erlang isn't good at
so in our case and and your mileage may
vary on this
in our case in our needs we found that
it was not suited
to work on large amount large amounts of
text
data or data that needed to become text
data
and it was also not designed to produce
large amounts of structured data
at least in our case and and i'll get
more into this in just a second but
that that was sort of some of the things
that we had to work around
so once we got this system working at
the most basic levels this is running
locally on machines and running a few
test environments
we essentially we started dealing with
the performance of it in
in a authoritative dns server the idea
is to have low latency
all right the idea is to have the the
packet the time from the packet coming
in and to a response going back to the
customer you want to get that as low as
possible and there's a lot of factors
there's network there's there's actually
cpu pro in our case
there's all kinds of these different
factors so these are
i'm just going to give you a few of the
things that that the performance
tuning that we did and when i say we i
wasn't alone on this darren helped me
out a lot on this as well
but it's these are a few of the things
that we had to do
the first thing was actually identify
those bottlenecks
and to do that we used two methods the
first was
looking from the outside in so the in
the remember i mentioned that the
problem with authoritative dns servers
is all of the edge cases
well the first thing that i had to do
was was come to have a decent test suite
that could show all of these edge cases
fortunately the folks at powerdns had
already built this
all right so i took their test suite and
started running
a variation of their test suite because
i re-implemented it so it was easier for
me to
mutate a little bit because we had
additional tests we not wanted to add on
top of it
and their test suite was a bunch of
folders with shell scripts inside of
them
so i essentially took that and defined
an erlang test suite
that would sit and query our name
servers well once we got the correctness
right and that took a while
then we started going what if we
actually start timing all of these
queries as they appear from the outside
just running in a local environment
you know one time two three times it
basically do some sampling on it
and really quickly we found that okay
there are some issues here
where it will take say you know hundreds
of milliseconds for a response to come
back
well this is a problem all right we want
to come back we don't want
the app to be the source of the latency
we want the latency to be at the network
level because that we can optimize
uh even more with different network
strategies so
the other thing we measured then was
inside so
we have the outside here that's
measuring the questions coming in and
the response times come back
then we also started looking for hot
spots inside of the application
sorry measuring there once we started
figuring out where it was it became
obvious
andel's law okay is in full force here
essentially saying the speed up of a
program using multiple processors and
parallel computing is limited by the
time
needed for the sequential fraction of
the program to execute all right and in
our case
at the time of when i started building
this the sequential portion
we had to figure out where it was and
push as like basically try to get
everything out of that so that was
responding the shortest time possible
you want to minimize the amount of time
spent in that single process and as soon
as possible hand off the request to
a process that can operate in parallel
fashion
now the thing that's interesting is you
have to actually be aware that the
handoff
becomes a factor in the performance and
in fact at very small times
the actual timing of the handoff
becomes a factor in the performance so
all these things play into
sort of optimizing this system for best
performance
the final thing was garbage collection
is pretty good in erlang
but it can still be an issue so if
you're creating processes and then
throwing them away
it's a lot of waste and the garbage
collector will eventually come in and it
will start causing problems
so the that became a factor as well in
the optimization so where did we end up
once we started to realize what these
different elements were to optimize
um so the the single process is reading
the packet out of the udp
uh port basically so prior to linux
three nine
uh only a single process could read from
a particular udp port
so that was our that was our bottleneck
right there uh so initially we measured
from the outside and then we measured
from the inside and actually timed
the amount of time it took and it wasn't
like we just immediately knew that
i essentially started working down from
the outside in so
from the resolving okay well the
resolving slow but
all the different pieces of the
resolving aren't necessarily slow so
there's something else in it so i
started working
basically down uh this the stack until
we got down
to this tight loop the initial
implementation
had all of the processing on that type
loop well that's no
that's no good right because essentially
you're talking about a single
thread dealing or a single process all
the way through the request so you're
extremely limited
if a process is going to take you know
30 to 250 milliseconds
then you're you're talking about being
able to respond to four queries per
second this is no good
and you in dns land all right so
the next thing was to move to a pool of
processes that we could hand off to and
the first implementation we used was
pool boy
pool boy is sort of kind of a standard
pool and implementation and it's good
but when we came down to measuring it we
found that just handing off
to pool boy was taking four milliseconds
all right
so now i mean that implementation
already had a huge speed up we went from
four requests per second to
uh to what like 250 requests per second
okay this is a good jump but it's still
not good enough i had set a goal and i
said the goal was at least
a thousand requests per second right so
i want a million
millisecond or sub millisecond response
time like times for
doing this hand-off so the final thing
that we ended up on
was this usually basically using an a
cue structure
that's already inside of erlang to hand
off workers
and this queue has a limited size
which is construct which is defined
basically in the beginning this is the
implementation of handling request as it
is today
essentially pull a worker out of the
queue from this collection of workers
that we have
um and then we attempt to cast so again
remember that's an asynchronous call
the worker's an independent process we
don't care if it returns because the
worker is going to have a reference
to the udp like to the udp address
that sent the question so we can just
respond back by sending a message back
to it
if the queue is empty then we just drop
the packet
all right so this is like this is we're
going to keep running but we'll start
failing by dropping packets
that was that was the first
implementation and the current
implementation actually and it works
pretty well
for the size of data that's going
through here now this is the actual part
that calls that and as it is today
so essentially every time youtube packet
comes in
we're using folsom now to measure how
long it takes to
hand that packet off the
the request is essentially sent through
the handle request function
with the socket the host the port the
binary data and the current state
and then we're using active once so
every time that we get a question we
then turn the socket back to active once
it's basically it means we control the
flow of packets into the system
we don't let the os really control the
flow of packets right we're
we're controlling just for that one
request and we keep doing that every
time
so this is it's gonna be a little tough
to see this i know i'll give you the
numbers essentially what we finally end
up with and this is on the operational
system right now
the the 99th percentile for handing off
these packets is anywhere from 35 to 60
microseconds
all right so this is a huge improvement
over what we were dealing with
originally
giving us the ability for one node
in our network to handle 17 to 25
000 requests per second all right way
above and beyond the thousand requests
per second that we originally that i was
my goal was so i was like this is great
so we're on the right path
because we have in our anycast network
40 nodes right now
meaning that we can handle anywhere from
say 650 000
to over a million questions per second
okay this is good
for our particular needs this is great
we handle we do domain resolution for
probably about
60 000 zones in total we're not anywhere
near that yet on our anycast network
but the point is is that we think that
we can handle it
um so a little bit more about that
process pool so like i said the number
of
of uh workers is configured externally
we can set it right now it's a
relatively low number but we can
increase as we need to
um it we don't ever increase or decrease
the size of the pool
it's fixed so that we know that there's
a fixed value if we wanted to decrease
or increase it we'd have to reconfigure
and restart
and the assumption is that all of those
workers are available in the queue will
finish before it hits the end of the
queue
if not we just drop the packet another
thing that we ended up doing is
initially we had a back-end database
similar to how power dns worked we were
talking directly to a mysql database
and then later a postgres database and
ultimately what we decided was
we need to bring all the zone data in
memory all right memory is cheap we've
got to be able to bring this stuff into
memory
and that way we remove all of the
overhead required to call out to a
database determine if a record even
exists
so now we do an in-memory cache um and
of course that presents its own set of
problems which is probably worth an
entire another talk
which is how hard cashing is all right
somebody at this conference has to talk
about this so
cashing is really hard it's really hard
to get rights but it's one of those
things that you pay that you sometimes
you need
in this case we're willing to pay the
price for that we do remote
zone loading from a special purpose
server remember back when i said that
one of the problems with erlang we had
to work around was some of its
text processing and the ability to
generate large amounts of structured
data
well the initial implementation of
erlang was relatively slow it took a
long time to generate our entire zone
data
into a structure that can be passed over
the network
well we ended up switching to go in that
particular case so the zone server is
written in go and the reason we chose go
is because it's
awesome for doing that particular thing
it's resource
the basically its use of memory and cpu
is amazing
and it's it's optimized for for
essentially it's optimized for web
services right and that's a lot about
parsing text data and pushing text data
back out so in this particular case we
let golang handle the production of that
zone data in a format that erlang is
ready to handle
and that way all we have to do is
basically parse that json at startup
time and bring it all into memory and
then we have other processes that are
used to update it
with only small zone changes we do
basically do just hey i'm going to
update this particular zone
for performance at this point initially
we're using the timer module manually
now we've moved to folsom for everything
which is a really awesome tool for
measuring all kinds of performance
performances metrics
for for counters it does um it does
histograms it does all kinds of really
neat things just stores the data and
then we push that
into an external service librato where
we can create graphs like the one i
showed before
that's really important as we go forward
and we start to identify new bottlenecks
um so where are we headed with this well
now in
in linux you can use so reuse port so
this potentially is
you allows us to have multiple processes
they're actually pulling
from the same udp port so
that potentially allows us let's say we
have four processes
now we can do four times on any one of
those particular nodes we don't need it
yet
but it's there now and that would be the
next step to go to it's not on all os's
though which is part of what makes a
challenge but in our case
where i have a homogeneous environment
or at least we can guarantee that we
have that
it's a lot easier for us to use things
like so
reuse port more metrics we have to
identify
the high latency paths and optimize
those
and then one of our big bottlenecks
right now is start up on the erlang side
when we
load the zones for all of our zones into
the into memory
it takes about a minute and a half to
warm that entire cache
that can be made parallel as well though
and all this and essentially when you're
building systems now all you
you start thinking about how can i make
something parallel right so that can be
parallelized by
having different processes look at
different chunks of the zone file
and then combine them back together at
the very end once they've done their
their
cpu intensive or memory intensive
processing and then the final thing is
command and control tools
uh some of that's going to be using
erlang itself there's a lot of command
like there's a lot of ways basically
where you can you can hook into a node
and start
like calling it's basically like a repo
right you can actually connect to a live
system but what's interesting is because
supposedly this is the theory right we
haven't put this in the play yet but you
can actually run a node locally
work with the repo there and send
messages to other nodes
that are distributed across other
systems so that's kind of one of the
tools
the other is i'm a big fan of having
sort of
hdp tools right because http is a
protocol that we can easily
get into we can have other languages
that are connecting to it and talking
and sort of taking data down
statistics or zone data and looking into
what the live system looks like
and then comparing that across all of
the the nodes
and determining is a node not updating
properly um
there's we could take this all kinds of
other steps further to the as we heard
from the previous talk
react does an amazing job as doing that
across a whole bunch of nodes as well so
that's another option as well
so ultimately we had to find erlang's
sweet spot
that's what this came down to and i
think in a lot of ways we found it and
the erlang sweet spot
is processes that are systems that are
going to run
that need to run for a long period of
time
and that need to if if they're going to
fail they're going to fail fast
allow you to fix what's failing and then
otherwise they're just going to run
non-stop and they're going to run allow
us to have built-in
parallel processing as part of the
language and the the
libraries so all this is an important
part of why
we ultimately chose erlang and the
decision has been a good one it's
not without challenges but at the same
time erlang has a lot of properties that
we found
that make some of this stuff really a
lot easier for us
all right and that's it for now i want
before i end and go into questions i'd
like to to mention um i don't have them
with me right now but if you catch me
later today
i brought some um some nougat from
i live in france and i brought some
nougat from france that's from a made in
a village right near where i live
and as long as you're not allergic to
peanuts honey or eggs
then they're awesome so uh find me later
if you're interested i have a few bags
of it
they're very good they're they're
excellent so um with that
i'm going to go into questions
question down front so uh you said if i
recall
you were evaluating different languages
for what you were going to re-implement
this and what are some of the other
things that you had evaluated
using and
could you maybe share some of your
experience with those sure so the
question is what other languages do we
evaluate
to to build this in as i mentioned
before
lua inside of powerdns was one of the
ones that we and i thought it was it was
very promising it looked like lou was
going to be a good solution
but the libraries for doing dns
resolution which is important part of
how our alias record works
just weren't working and so we were
spending a lot of time just trying to to
recompile things to get it to work and
it just
basically we got into a situation where
i was like okay we're spending too much
time we're not making headway
and it's no fun and one of the things
that's beautiful about running your own
company
is you can focus on doing the stuff that
you actually have fun at
all right and so that was this is one of
the impetuses right let's do something
that's fun
uh obviously we looked at a lot of some
of the other off the shelf
stuff that we could have looked at
there's some other c stuff out there
that looked out a little bit
part of what we wanted there was the
ability to to keep
building the system over time we wanted
something that was that was malleable
that we could
that we could add new features to and
actually enjoy it and one of the other
benefits which i didn't talk about which
but which i found is i think erlang is a
really good language
for adding new new things on top of
existing apps i mean there's a lot of
things that that
it supports both as a language this is
hot code swapping
not that we necessarily use it but it's
there as an option but it's also it's
just
it's easy to reason about how the system
operates because you have this clear
separation between
immutable data functions that process
immutable data and your state which is
all inside of processes
okay so that was another one go wasn't
at the point where there were dns
libraries at the time they are now and
in fact we use go for other things where
we're looking for
low memory and low cpu usage so really
highly optimized resource usage
because erlang kind of like the java vm
takes up a lot of memory and cpu
all right it's designed to do that
because it takes everything over
and so um go is a case where it's the
exact opposite go does not take over
anything
it combines compiles down to like the
the smallest thing can
uh the dependencies it minimizes
dependencies you can't define
dependencies
you don't actually use in go and so
therefore there are these properties of
go that we find
really useful for certain classes of
problems um so that's on the other one
yes question the back
uh have you guys using like pf
previously have we looked at using p
what
what are the names the answer would be
no because i came and i don't remember
the names or
uh something like user space drivers so
that you know
like you would essentially you were
talking about a thousand requests
you would essentially square that by
using uh
one of those
okay so have we looked at things that we
cut the kernel out uh not really not yet
no
i i'm not sure it would be i'm not sure
what the challenge is from doing that
inside of erlang would be
uh you know it's that we probably have
to fall down to see like get down to c
at that point
and um i'm just not a c programmer and
so the fact of the matter is is that
when i
i can read it but the amount of time i
would put into making it work right
and not like segfault all over the place
would probably exceed the amount of
benefit that i would get from doing it
considering we're already processing
you know the the tens of thousands to
100 thousands of queries per second
um sorry there was another question here
and then i'll get to you over here in
just one
transitioning to this second system and
you vote can you sort of explain what
the rollout process looked like because
that seemed kind of like a
scary thing to switch your authoritative
dns from your thread and butter and your
company over from
something that's you know commercial
so the question is what was the process
for rolling this out because it is a
sort of a frightening process to
to move our customers over from
something that's well established to
something that's not so well established
um it happened to coincide with a change
in our network we went from
having a unicast network which is where
essentially there's a single node that
can respond
to an uh to request to an ip address we
went from that to an anycast network
where we can have
nodes all over the world that basically
broadcast the same ip address and it's
up to the routing protocol to decide
which one it goes to
and so it just so happened that we had
this fresh environment to work with
where we could slowly move customers
over into it
we actually did try to roll out on our
unicast network early on
and this was before i had put the test
suite in place and
uh but we only rolled out yeah this
external test suite for the this i know
darren schleren's like
i'm cringing here this is the realities
of doing business though right so we
but we didn't roll out to everything we
rolled it out to just one server
which meant that the majority people
still got good answers
but some people in edge cases were not
and as soon as we started getting
complaints we're like okay roll it back
let's start looking at it again and we
we tried that a few times and ultimately
the anycast network would let us have a
free space to work in
so we could start smaller and grow it
back out which is why we're still
running two parallel networks we have
the unicast which is still running power
dns
and the anycast which is running this
new system as well you had a question
over
per here how fast was the old one and
does that stuff make a difference just
for the number of servers you have to
have or is it a difference for the end
user
right okay so the question is how did
the old system perform
uh compared to the new system how many
requests per second
and was there a perceived
result to the end user so
the answer is the power dns for all
queries that are
that you can respond to by a database
query so basically anything that's a
simple response
it's very fast for so it was doing
thousands of requests per second
um without any trouble all right like it
the the usage wasn't significant uh
it wasn't that that was causing the
problem is our customizations
for non-standard records that was
causing the problem
so when we switched over the goal wasn't
actually to have any perceived
difference
from the system so we didn't want to
make it faster
we just didn't want to make it slower we
didn't want to introduce new latency we
wanted to keep the levels at the same
and ultimately we were able to do that
then
with the anycast network that's where we
do the optimizations where the
customers see a benefit because now
they're rout
there's fewer hops to get to their name
server the name server responds in the
same fashion which is usually pretty
fast
and then the the data gets back it's
actually the latency between
the resolver and the authoritative name
server that's
more of a problem that represents the
largest amount of latency not the actual
system run itself
yes
it already is yes so it and i i can't
remember if it's under my name so i'm a
eden on github
and the company is h yeah yeah it's
under a trend
okay so the test suite earl dns is
already under atron atrion is ae
in fact let me move on to here just so
you can see this so that's the url
for the earl dns open source project
and then in that same repository there's
another open source project that's
called like earl test
or dns test or something like i can't
remember what i called it um then that's
open source as well and i attempt to
as the powerdns one develops i attempt
to develop rs in parallel
they're much further along with things
like um
like dns sec so they have a whole bunch
of tests that are around dns sec which
is basically allowing you to sign
zones we don't do any of that stuff yet
and so therefore that
that part of test test suite's not
implemented yet but the basic parts of
the test suite are implemented
and i'm pretty happy with that yes you
have a question
at this point if you're on the anycast
it's essentially adding nodes
which is the beauty of it in the unicast
we we started hitting
the where we couldn't add more nodes
because it was a single
ip like the single node behind that ip
address and that's why we said
ultimately we had to move to any cast
we had to do the capital investment to
do so but
right now no we just add nodes onto
anycast network is the
and that's the long-term goal um i'm out
of time thank you everyone for coming
and
enjoy the rest of the conference